so just imagine that there are four
mechanically sound ways of moving and
less mechanically sound ways there's
better bridges and less better bridges
okay so they the assumption is always in
katate dori that you can just do
whatever you can
then wrist angle the handshake the elbow
angle the shoulder I can go it was all
very important
every time you deviate from that you
have issues okay so you're not learning
the wrist grab you're more interested in
this biomechanical geometry right and of
course it extends below but we're not
going to deal with that today just deal
with the arm okay
you're too straight to event to out to
in is happening all the time okay so if
I if I take could touch the dirty and
then bring my hands up right not like
I'm gonna do a technique because now
everyone's closer to this you see but if
I just bring my hands I end up here
slightly in slightly forward elbows
underneath okay
that's what we're trying to work on so
this angle helps going to be force helps
let's just look at one thing
this is the best angle for generating a
resistance
energy to his resistance okay so I don't
want to push like this it takes it and
puts it somewhere else in my inner
deltoids and outer pitfalls I don't I
don't want it there
I want my my back you see my back go
like this this is now something else
okay
so this one too is because of its shape
and I'm just going to mention this here
is this is what actually generates the
pressure into my heart up and starts to
utilize it when you go when you go like
this goes up high because it doesn't aim
down okay so we're gonna look at the arm
to start with the arm okay look at my
angle of my bra just forget like there's
any lower arm
mid to upper arm okay and he's going to
push and usually when he pushes here you
you will start to feel the pressure to
come up it'll come around this auto pan
okay and you see he can't put on the
armor straight so when I go like this I
can't really you can't push them right
and they can't be too close right
because he just pushes it at my ribcage
so there becomes like unmovable thing
that is there
and this is what we referred to as elbow
power it's the elbow is being energized
where it is its most efficient place to
speak okay so you can just hang out here
there's no hinge in my it between my
elbow my shoulder I just hang out of
here okay don't worry what this arm is
doing right now just focus on that elbow
being in that place where I can hang out
all of it
the now user is trying to be and we're
going to increase the way what I'm doing
the same thing she's not don't hate
don't worry about what the lower
just leave that elbow right in that spot
yeah
so see how it's too high
okay so when I say in don't go like that
if you move the whole thing okay this
arm has the lower has so much range in
its arc of movement it becomes the elbow
came up you see this would be too much
and then if the hand goes down and the
elbow disappears so you only have elbow
there and I only got go any lower and
leave that there and then
and I lose no structural integrity
resisting his energy at the elbow by
doing that you see that you guys see
that himself I go like that
like that
see so to keep that we're gonna push
hard and push hard and I leave I leave
all that there okay
go see if you could tell me what the
difference between these two examples
that's example a Bashar
what is that
but okay B moves more freely a had more
tension in it right what's holding the
arm in place his push from what is it my
elbow what does this have to do with
anything
he's a nothing nothing to get it
so if I if I am keeping that in place
with and I have to go slow like that I'm
probably keeping it in place with this
hand and that we don't want that you
want the hover over the lower arm is
doing this thing it's not important okay
try it again so this one depends on you
care okay so who cares got to really try
you can't you guys just trying to shove
me and we can't does not change
direction okay so I'm now going to move
my elbow in space meaning when you can
feel the whole hookah hookah doesn't
start changing the
okay so again the arm was nothing I'm
just going to turn my elbow into space
no you're changing your name
you see
don't do stuff with your floor on
everything is with the elbow
and look I'm starting this way to help
you so is there a push we're not going
anywhere and I start to drill what
technique is that it need me not yet you
see right here and I turned my elbow
it's also that elbows from the last
class
Oh same thing so we're here keep that
tight and I don't lose the structural
integrity but I create what's tell push
hard watch what's happening we shark
I add my hip and shoulder which way to
go forward you see now I can do a Yid
space in the midst of a young integrity
I don't need any arm power okay well
here's the thing we're down here like
this and this was not relevant
it stays not relevant it's here okay it
will become relevant if you lose the
elbow angle you're gonna have make down
this and this well I keep the elbow
angle right and I do this same thing you
guys see that
410 is a push it on your elbow elbow
okay try again what I'm trying to tell
you is when you when you feel it here or
here or someplace other than here it is
because you change that that elbow angle
so you went you did something you see
that see that if I was doing the first
drill this would not work okay so come
on over here and you come push on that
same that same elbow spot you're trying
to push your transmission be this way
st. replace and we go to head inside
he's pushing he was he had this hanging
here this I don't feel anything in my
arm okay now he's there and he's there
so to try to help me you're still
pushing this right and don't want to
lose his pressure want to do this thing
technique want use problem hey hey and I
think of moving him do you understand
you're gonna be increased don't think I
him don't think I'm going to talk to
dirty guys think of that elbow guy and
you do the same elbow drill okay
can't go
okay
don't look for what they're don't don't
try to go like this it's a way of moving
that we want it's not them falling so
I'm here like that and I just do the
shape they're doing their jobs this is
just a rule of blue candy right
I am NOT trying to get that look that is
not mechanically sound I'm here I have
that same pressure in the elbow and I'm
going to turn the elbow that's all there
is to it
they focus what they're doing okay
that's what happens when you become
preoccupied by them if you start lifting
okay see now now you're not worthy
okay now you're not learning here he
does what he's doing that's why I keep
correct
I go on okay now it's going this way
get yourself where you can be so you can
push straight okay here's where I am and
now I just turn my spin this and turn it
upside down okay come okay so now we'll
go back to another pressure girl and I
have high elbows here's where we started
my are my upper arms or I'm gonna have
the forearms aren't really doing
anything okay the structure is and the
elbows have been down to the core so
these are here fine if I start going
like this I'm changing the elbow shape
you see that came up I said I'm going
like that I'm changing the other shape
so here is he's pushing you can do it
where he's in front
right
[Music]
and we're gonna be here all all day long
okay and if he lets go really fast you
see how I was not Gracie okay
so play with your amount of that you can
do here but pay attention to everything
we've done up till now this will be the
least seated push these with his
forearms see that's parallel out of the
shoulder
this is going right about that level
there remember what I started this way
did I really was more and more new
students that the pressures coming down
me down in here okay
so I walked out when I don't want to
just hold it off you see that I want the
pressure in here feel the ground
pressure and the holoband is starting to
swell
okay not not up like this is to one box
for me I gotta get back in position
and feelings
and so when I move that you see I do not
move it well I can't move my arm but if
I move my arm against that's much
turning to pleases everyone but once and
let me get a place once I get all this
year going then and that's well sent
when I moved my body
he was you see over here I'm not gone
like this swell
this is not relevant if I want my elbows
to come up in space body moves
[Music]